with this kiss I pledge my love the
wedding staging that was a huge
challenge it's the first and last time
we'll ever have this many main
characters in the same place at the same
time it's the massive team which takes
up about half the episode and the movie
we probably would have had two weeks to
shoot a scene that's gonna end up taking
about 24 minutes of screen time and we
have to do it in four days the ceremony
itself was very decadent and Joffrey and
Margaery were the centerpieces I wanted
it to look as royal as possible we did
the wedding as if they opened all the
doors in the Sept because the Sept has
always been almost to Mike the dress is
just beautifully designed it's every
girl's princess fantasy dream really
and what did just be sort of quite a
traditional dress so it was a bit of a
labor of love when you read the winning
face and script it it's completely mad
doves coming out of a big pie you have a
giant lions head it was just such an
enormous set and so many extras and so
much main action was the biggest thing
that King's Landing has basically ever
seen we were very lucky that we had Alex
graves as our director it's a scene that
he's been preparing for for months and
months I wanted it to be this beautiful
sunny day very not Game of Thrones
hopefully the audience will be thinking
something really bad is going to happen
I don't understand what it is but I know
it's coming so that when Joffrey started
to have you know his mood swings you
just went oh my god there's been too
much amusement here today a royal
wedding is not an amusement Joffrey has
arranged a troop of dwarves to reenact
his victories over the other armies
which Joffrey knows humiliating to
Tyrion Joffrey gives birth to this idea
and so it's you know
fittingly idiotic and insulting and his
enjoyment of it makes it more so for me
as an actor it made me uncomfortable in
a really good way I loved that they took
that leap uncle you can be my cupbearer
seeing as you're too cowardly to fight
your grace does me a great honor it's
not meant as an honor
Joffrey wants to humiliate Tyrion and
take him under his control Tyrion has
never been faced with this much public
humiliation because he usually has an
answer for it
he's usually center stage and he usually
is better at it than the people around
him but this time around it's quite
shocking and he's left as a as an
audience member
this is Joffrey's house as Joffrey's
rules and if you mess around you're
gonna be humiliated in the middle of the
growing tension all of a sudden Margery
system she calms the mood for a moment
at least so he leaves Tyrians torment
just for a brief moment Margaery
genuinely doesn't realise what's
happening when Joffrey starts to show
signs of being uncomfortable and then
obviously it's a very steep very quick
violent deterioration you would think
that when you have a villain like
Joffrey no matter how loathsome a human
being might be it's still a human being
on the one hand no one deserved it more
than Joffrey and on the other hand
you're seeing a mother watch her
firstborn child die and an incredibly
painful way one of the things that we
loved about Joffrey's death in the books
and hopefully replicated in the show is
both how anticlimactic his death is and
how human it is I love Jack just looked
him and I would tear up because I was
like he's gonna be gone you know and
he's such a great prisoners you see him
suddenly died in that spectacular
fashion it's sad but it's very true to
the story and true to this world just
because you die and you leave doesn't
mean you're not part of the family
anymore
once Game of Thrones family always Game
of Thrones family I miss playing a fun
character but nothing two bears to
everyone here I miss them a lot
[Music]